[Music]
foreign you are watching The Press
previewer first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive it's time to
see what's making the headlines with the
Guardians Deputy political editor
Jessica elgot and the pr consultant Alex
Dean they'll be with us from now until
just before midnight so let's see what's
on some of those front pages for you now
with the prince and a princess of Wales
in Boston the Metro highlights the
release of a trailer for Harry and
Megan's Netflix documentary with a
headline now it's our turn
the express asked Harry do you really
hate your family so much
while the star opts for full-blown
sarcasm declaring publicity shy couple
share most intimate secrets with 8
billion people
as the sun puts it kiss Means War
the eye warns that raw male could
struggle to cope with demand over
Christmas
while the guardian claims an exclusive
with views that health union Chiefs are
meeting to plan a joint strike across
the festive period
strikes lead the times two with an
appeal from ministers to the Rel unions
to call a festive truce in their
industrial action
the telegraph reports that Downing
Street is backtracking on a new free
speech law which would stop universities
canceling appearances by controversial
speakers
the national from Scotland reports on
the resignation of Ian Blackford as the
smp's leader in Westminster
the mail carries extracts from the
former Health secretary Matt Hancock's
new book in which he reveals a plan to
release thousands of prisoners that was
under discussion at the height of the
pandemic
and the financial times has a story
concerning the troubled Investment Bank
Blackstone
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Jessica elgot and Alex Dean welcome to
both of you let us start with the metro
and uh pictured on the front page Harry
and Megan with the headline now it's our
turn Jessica take us into this
okay so this is a new
um Netflix documentary and uh purporting
to show Harry and Megan's side of the
story I think it's something that that
Megan alluded to in a in another
interview that she did
um where she said that she we kind of
wanted to tell the the couple's story
their love story that hadn't been
um you know hadn't really been out there
before and you know some of the language
used to describe it was quite
interesting whereas you know nobody sees
what goes on behind
closed doors is one of the things that
Harry said and you can see why some of
the papers have adopted a bit of a
sarcastic tone to that because
I think you know obviously one of the
reasons that the couple gay was for for
leaving was was you know having their
private life so much in the spotlight
having people kind of speculate what was
going on behind closed doors you know
too much or being too much subject to
press intrusion and some of that you
know probably totally valid
um but I think it is it's obviously
awkward timing with
um the prince of Princess of Wales in
the US do you think it's deliberate do
you think it's deliberate timing do you
think it's deliberate timing on or not
uh yeah I think it is I mean I think
that marketing people to you know tend
to know what they're doing
um I think probably what is not what is
something that you don't that you that
you know that you can't really time is
that it comes after yesterday's route
about
um you know an incident at the palace
where you know where where someone was
quizzed
um very heavily on their on their
background and what country they came
from and obviously that that is that
sits quite awkwardly with the way that
Megan describes being treated in in a
sort of racially insensitive Ways by the
by the palace herself so
um that I don't think you could really
plot around but yes of course it feels
likely that that there is some element
of of timing around it with with this
visit to the US yeah and Alex another
quote from the the trail for this
documentary from uh Megan herself saying
when the stakes are this High doesn't it
make sense to hear our story from us is
that a valid point that they get to tell
their own story in their own words
well I think part of it's absolutely
valid the notion that there's a love
story here between these two people I
think that's a completely valid point
but I think Jessica puts her finger on
the hypocrisy that many of us will feel
seeing
um these headlines
um I as a monarchist find it rather
difficult because I want to be on the
side of of these people but you can't
help but feel like we're being taken for
a ride now as the people who said that
they wanted to protect their privacy
launch their Netflix show and go after
another
um photo opportunity at one after
another now I I actually I think we may
disagree slightly about the timing
um I agree with Jessica that they can't
possibly have timed it with regard to
the incident of the Buckingham Palace
but I I'm I would like to be charitable
and think that it was not deliberate
with regard to the royal visit to the
United States and that may sound naive
but I would really like to think and
hope that no man would do this to his
brother and that Harry and William who
are all things being equal are still
brothers and are still pretty close as
we've seen in in recent times for
obvious reasons after the death of her
majesty the queen I just cannot believe
that Harry would countenance sticking it
to his brother in such a deliberate way
so naive as it may sound I'm going to
hope and say that my view is that it's a
coincidence and Jessica do you think
that the visit by the Princeton Princess
of Wales An American in Boston at the
moment do you think that has been
overshadowed by the the trail that's
been put out and also by the the
incident in Buckingham Palace
mostly these kinds of stories are by and
large more interesting than the prince
and maybe I sound cynical more
interesting than the prince and princess
of Wales doing kind of routine visits to
to places in in the United States uh I
mean your viewers might find what
they're doing over there very very
interesting but you know I think that
probably there are there are things of
Greater interest to the British public
so it's not very difficult to overshadow
what they're doing if that's that overly
cynical
um but I think you know probably
um it's not the the best start from them
and and going to the US is probably
always going to be slightly more
difficult than it was for for
um William and Kate because I think
there was a real feeling over there of
solidarity um with Megan and the way
that she's been treated and
um you certainly saw that I think there
was there was some booing when the
pictures of them were shown
um at a sports game so
um I think you know more more so than
ever there's a kind of a delicacy around
these International trip that Royals
will take you know probably from now on
and Alex what do you think that the
public feeling is here towards Harry and
Megan we look at the start it's a very
sarcastic headline they're saying
publicity shy couples share most
intimate secrets with eight billion
people
yeah God bless the star I rather like
this that that summed up my view that
they've been so uh faux Coy with the
idea they want to protect their privacy
whilst
um doing things like this constantly I
mean I thought that the Stars front page
was spot on actually I think that a lot
of people in this country started with
enormous Goodwill towards Harry and
Megan and as they've seen them stick it
towards Harry's own family not least
making it very hard I think for the
queen in her last months I think that
that sympathy has waned quite
considerably so I think the sarcasm that
these star shows is probably pretty
demonstrative of public opinion here in
the UK but Jessica do you think that the
public will be interested to to hear
their story in the in their own words
I'm pretty sure that this Netflix
documentary is going to get an enormous
viewership in the UK I mean I think yeah
we say that people don't people are
gonna you know shun it because they feel
it's distasteful I just I just don't
think that's human I just don't think
that's human nature or human behavior I
mean I think people are going to be
fascinated in the same way as they saw
um you know the Oprah Winfrey
um uh documentary I struggle to see what
what more there is to say even if I
found some of the stuff that Megan said
you know in that in that Oprah Winfrey
interview quite shocking and you know
sort of potentially justifiable to speak
out about but I do struggle with what
what new information we can possibly
have about this couple now but
um but I think you know regardless of
that there's there's certainly going to
be extraordinary interest I would
imagine yes we shall see we shall see
let's move on to another story now the
front of the guardian and this is the
the possibility of coordinated strikes
to impose Maximum Impact Alex
it's a real shame I think I know that
people
um who are in charge of unions naturally
seek to coordinate their activities at a
time that will have Maximum Impact but I
mean any uh strike in the NHS is going
to trigger
um huge upset especially with the
backlog Post cover that we've got for
various operations and appointments but
the notion that people would scheme to
seek to strike over Christmas seems to
me particularly ill-judged the National
Health Services is held up in our
country as a great Institution for which
everyone has respect and they really do
run the risk I think of eroding at that
with things like this I think that um of
course in the cost of living crisis
people expect to see pay Rises pretty
much across the board but many people
will look at the offer that was made to
nursing staff and others and think well
even if you're not going to settle for
that at least you should keep
negotiating and not withdraw your labor
and not have a strike during Christmas
and I think it would be really bad to
have we've seen all these other strikes
that are coming out Rail and post and
others I think it'd be really bad to see
our health Healthcare staff walk out
during Christmas and I think it would
harm that position in the public quite
considerably we read that the NHS will
grind to a halt on the 20th of December
that's the date that that's being um
considered coordinated Christmas strike
in England and Wales by nurses ambulance
workers and hospital staff and these
discussions are continuing and the
growing consensus is that the 20th of
December will be the date for um as as
we say Maximum Impact Jessica
yeah and you can and and you know like
Alex says it's not it's not unheard of
for for unions to coordinate
um strike action in order to have the
impact because you know the point of a
strike is to have impact
um and you know the point of withdrawing
your labor is to make the point that you
don't feel negotiations are are getting
anywhere and you know for nurses this is
the the first striking I think more than
a century
um and at the moment the payoffer isn't
anywhere near
um you know what they would deem to be
acceptable and the government's been
using quite Hardline rhetoric about
um you know it being completely
unaffordable
um to give them you know more you know a
bigger rise when you know frankly when
we've just seen pensioners in the triple
lock get there getting you know get a 10
rise and and you know in their in their
pension and that's probably rightly so
but we're not seeing you know working
people necessarily get anything like
that kind of Rise
um and you know deals have been done uh
actually
um with nursing staff
um still below inflation pay Rises but
bigger pay rises in in Scotland and in
Wales so
um there's clearly
um it's clearly a union that's that's
open to some compromise
um and I think you know the feeling I
get when I'm you know speaking to people
there is that you know they really
nurses don't really want to strike and
and I think they understand you know
what it you know that that they might be
the target of some public anger if they
do so
um I think there is some still still
some hope of being able to to avert it
um but you know there is obviously a
move into contingency planning now and
how you
um still provide a service that doesn't
actually put the people at risk in the
way that you might have a kind of
Christmas Day level of of Staffing where
you can't you know people's operations
might get canceled routine appointments
might get canceled but you still you
know have that life-saving care
available yes the number 10 is
urging uh the unions to consider the
impact on patients and have said that
public sector pay Awards must be
affordable for the taxpayer um just for
the break let's take a look at the
Telegraph and this is a piece about um
the government rowing back on uh
University Free Speech law that they
were putting forth and now seemingly
watering it down Alex
yeah that's right instead of the uh
previous uh proposals which were quite
um stringent on free speech on campus
there's now a complaints procedure
that's been put forward
um by government on the one hand
um one hears the people who've been
so-called canceled under recent events
and understands why they are frustrated
by what the government is now saying
there are several high-profile uh people
who've been denied their ability to
speak at universities and and so forth
who are very frustrated that there's not
more being done and that's the telegraph
uses some very
um powerful examples emotive examples of
people who've been canceled on various
high-profile issues on the other hand
you've got a wonder if you try to force
this on universities isn't the natural
result that they stop inviting people in
the first place and I think that whilst
I appreciate some of this has been
clamping down on individual societies
they've invited people that the broader
authorities in University didn't want to
invite in the first place in the end it
seems that there's going to be a
chilling effect on campus per se because
of the work agenda whatever government
does I like the idea that government
should try to protect free speech on
campus and elsewhere but in the end you
cannot tell people to love free speech
and then see them do so it's not
something that you can order by Fiat or
by law it has to be something that you
encourage and seek to inculcate in a
culture I don't think you can demand it
and then see it flourish
thank you both we have run out of time
before the break we'll see you after uh
said break but coming up fresh from the
jungle Matt Hancock has a new book on
the way we'll be discussing that when we
come back and it's starting Revelations
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
previews to with me Jessica algott and
Alex Dean let us have a look at the
national and in Blackford pictured on
the front page uh decision to resign as
SMP group leader we read
um tell us a bit more about the
background to this Jessica
yeah so so Ian Blackford you know saying
this is you know it's time for fresh
leadership
um uh and he would have been you know it
would have been stunning again at the
the AGM of the Westminster group next
week but this comes after you know
essentially repeated attempts by his own
MPS to oust him in favor of a new
generation of uh of of of SNP MPS and
um he's you know been a particular
Target for for plotting within the ranks
um and it is something that I think
reflects probably on on Nicholas
sturgeon's Authority as well because
some of her closest aides were were kind
of trying to keep him as in post as
recently as as last week
um uh but
um you know we're reporting tonight uh
amongst others that
um Stephen Flynn who's the Aberdeen
South MP has you know essentially told
Blackfoot that he's got you know the
necessary support amongst colleagues and
in Westminster to to
oust him if he if he did stand so it
seems like
um you know that's the you know that's
been the the driving point and the the
thing that tipped him over over the edge
today to to announce that he wouldn't
stand again so slight slightly pushed as
is what you're saying um let's uh we're
running out of time but I just want to
get to to this last story Alex on the
front page of the Daily Mail Matt
Hancock's out of the Jungle uh surprise
surprise has a book out and there are
some startling Revelations
that's right not least the suggestion
that there was a plan during the worst
times in coronavirus to effectively
release a number of people who should be
in prison it sounds more like the sort
of thing that happens in banana
republics where
um you know you the state can't afford
to keep people locked up anymore so they
have to let them out and it's it does
make you reflect on and look back on
quite how far we went as a country to
contemplate the notion that uh criminals
in quite some serious um criminality
would be effectively uh if not pardoned
and have an amnesty because the state
couldn't manage to keep you in prison
any longer I get having people in close
proximity to one another and having a
liberty curtail pose unique challenges
during coronavirus but surely we as a
civilized country had the wherewithal
both to maintain our coronavirus
procedures and keep dangerous criminals
off the street so it's quite alarming to
see that this was proposed and I'm very
glad it didn't happen Jessica should he
be allowed to reveal details such as
this
um well I mean I think that everybody
else is going to be be doing those kinds
of things aren't they I mean you know I
I think that there's I think to a
certain extent this is what political
biographies always do and don't forget
we've got we've got what will be a
fairly intensive um public inquiry
um coming through you know coming down
the track that Matt Hancock will have to
spend an awful lot of time giving
evidence to and you might argue that the
right forum for this kind of thing to
come out and be analyzed um it is in a
public inquiry where
um you know the evidence for breather
can be weighed up but uh but it's not
surprising he's making money out of it
Jessica and Alex see you in the next
hour thank you so much for the moment